It's a Saturday for me in Los Angeles,
and because I am a total space nerd
I've come to North
Hollywood to Norton Sales.
This place is legendary
in the aerospace industry.
For decades they've been hoarding
any sort of space junk they could get.
No less than a young pup of an Elon Musk
and a equally puppy Peter
Beck from Rocket Lab
came here before they started
their giant space companies.
Can look around, find
a valve, many valves,
a turbo pump, whatever you need.
If you've seen the Mandalorian,
Star Trek, Star Wars,
pretty good chance they
picked up a few objects
from this place.
Three, two, one, zero, liftoff.
We have a liftoff.
If you too, want to get
space junk, you should come,
and if nothing else, you can sit in a pod.
Los Angeles's aerospace
history goes back 100 years.
Some of the first plane
companies were here.
Some of the first rocket
experimenters too.
LA helped turn the US into
an aerospace superpower.
The old guard is still here.
But now there's Elon Musk's SpaceX
and a half dozen more rocket startups.
Not to mention myriad more new satellite
and space manufacturing companies.
SpaceX has turned into the towering giant
of commercial space.
And many of its spawn have
turned LA into the centre
of the commercial space revolution.
As luck would have it,
I know just the man to
explain how this happened
and where this is all heading.
If you are a nerd like me,
LA can be a magical place.
You can be by an oil refinery
and then a space startup at the same time.
I'm here to meet Tom Mueller.
He's the CEO of a startup
called Impulse Space.
He's the dude who built the
first engines for SpaceX.
He's a gear head. He's my kind of people.
And I think you all should come meet Tom.
This was the engine that
I designed, actually,
before we even incorporated Impulse.
This was just floating
around in your head?
Just floating around.
I don't know. It just
snowballed and became a company.
Yeah.
Here we go. We're off and running.
Can we check out this guy?
Yeah.
My relationship with Tom
goes something like this:
He makes cool space hardware,
then tries to explain it to
me while I nod and smile.
If you, if you burn
past that, you have what
what are called cosine losses.
Okay.
So you just do a whole
bunch of short burns
like when you're doing
the Holman transfers
you have a huge float. Say
you're going from Leo to Geo,
and you got to do
Well, that's going to take, you know-
The man has a beautiful mind
and after 18 years
sweating it out under Elon,
he started his own space company, Impulse.
I will show you its wonders
in a minute, but first,
Tom offered to drive me around town
in one of his many fast cars.
Oh yeah.
In addition to being a rocket
God, he's an amateur racer.
Yes.
How many tickets have you gotten in LA?
I haven't had any lately,
but I've gotten quite a few.
So the racing, you just
jumped into it and you just-
Yeah. It's pretty addicting.
You wouldn't be doing it
unless it was fun because
it's crazy expensive.
He may spend his spare
time racing Porsches now,
but Tom comes from humble roots.
You're an Idaho man originally.
Yeah. Born and raised.
Me and my brother were pretty
wild riding bikes, hiking,
going out in the woods
and playing all the time.
When did it become obvious
to you that you were going
to build rocket engines?
I forget where I saw it,
of course, but, you know,
in some magazine or
something, you fill out a form
and you order these Estes rockets
and wait weeks for it to come.
The model rockets.
Yeah. The little model rockets.
Yeah, the kits.
The little kits. And I
built a lot of those.
And then I got into high school
and took a math class
and my math teacher said,
"Wow, Tom, you're really good at math.
Yeah. You're going to
be an engineer, right?"
I go, "No, I'm going to
be an aircraft mechanic."
He's like, "Do you want to
be the guy that fixes a plane
or the guy that designs a plane?"
That totally changed my life.
When did you first move to LA?
1985.
The aerospace industry has
had so many ups and downs.
When you arrived, was it a boom cycle or?
It was a boom, it was the Reagan era.
Star Wars and all that was going on.
Yeah.
So it was the good times.
Tom worked for the next decade and a half
at companies like Hughes Aircraft and TRW,
but then LA's space scene,
and the space scene in general
hit a major funk.
Innovation stalled,
government and military
bureaucracy reigned supreme.
And then out of nowhere, the
PayPal guy turned up in LA
and started talking about his dream
to build a colony on the red planet.
I don't think we should
be going back to the moon.
I think we should be focused on Mars.
Half the people, well, more than half
would be telling this guy,
Elon, that that's crazy.
But then there's, there's
going to be this group
of people that want to
give it a go, right?
Yeah.
And you, you end up as one of those.
Yep. Yeah, I think there's
a lot of naysayers.
I was not able to hire
very many people early on
because they just didn't think
a small company could do it.
Right? But Elon, you know,
he just has this spirit like,
we're going to do it,
come hell or high water.
Alright, now this is the
building right up here.
The first SpaceX building?
Yeah.
Oh, it is a fish place now.
How long were you guys here?
It was the first what?
I think we moved in at about June of 2002.
So it was five years.
The machine shop was
straight back here and
we built the first Falcon
9, first stage in here
and famously had to
remove all the landscaping
to get it out.
So shouldn't this be
a historical landmark or something?
Yeah. It's funny that it's a fish market.
Traditional aerospace
folks thought of SpaceX
as a complete joke and
the company had plenty
of struggles during its first years.
Still, Tom and the rest of
the SpaceX team kept at it.
They built their engines
named Merlin and Kestrel
in California, and then
commuted to Texas to test them.
Sometimes they worked,
sometimes they didn't.
In 2008, all the hard work paid
off in spectacular fashion.
SpaceX made it to orbit
with a liquid fueled rocket,
a first for a private rocket company.
Elon always knew that we were
going to be super successful.
Like he always said, someday
our name's going to be
as big as Boeing's.
And I'm like, yeah, yeah, right.
Holy. He was right.
Tom didn't make much money at SpaceX,
but his pride and his accomplishments
keeps him warm at night.
Stop it, hit the middle button
and then you hit it and
it'll go the other way.
Just kidding. He's loaded.
This is when you know you've made it,
when you've got a Ferrari
spinning around in here.
I'm blessed.
In your garage.
SpaceX has been very good to me.
Are you worried that you have a problem?
Oh, I definitely have a problem.
Then there's the decked out home workshop
where Tom can relive his glory
days flying hobbyist rockets.
So this is probably the smallest
liquid rocket ever flown.
25 pounds of thrust, inch
and a half in diameter.
It's kind of like a cool part of
southern California though, is this
whole thing where you can go from LA
to Mojave and just go
do whatever you want.
Two. One. Ignition
Looks like we might be able to
salvage the engine on this even.
Look what came out of it, you know?
Because I was known for making nice parts,
when Elon came and he knew
some people in the club,
he said "Hey, I need an engine guy."
They recommended me and
that's how it happened.
Alright. We got to be careful.
This is a construction zone out here
And of course the greatest
man cave of all time.
So this is the Merlin 1A.
So this was the original flight engine
that we flew on the first two flights.
I know every part of this thing.
I've machined panel tips for this thing,
and we lived this engine.
The room is filled with the spoils
of Tom's four decade career in aerospace.
This right here is a LEM D injector.
This is what they landed on the moon.
When Armstrong was throttling,
trying to find a place to land,
he was throttling this engine.
Eagle, looking great. You're go.
If you're anything like me,
you could spend days
here, but there's no time
to hang around with relics of the past.
Next stop LA's Aerospace future.
Right when I started
covering SpaceX, it was like,
the US aerospace industry's
really sad and depressing
and young people didn't
want to work there.
And then you guys were at
it for now these 20 years,
but now there's no more
exciting country anywhere.
Not only do we have SpaceX,
but we've got small rocket makers,
we've got tons of satellites.
Everything just the
flywheel effect of SpaceX
has started the space -
Really this is the modern era.
The space age started right there.
Now that companies like SpaceX have made
getting off-planet relatively affordable,
space ventures are popping up all over LA
cooking up wild ideas to try out in orbit.
Like Varda Space Industries run
by William here, a spaceX ex.
They set up shop a couple of years ago
in this former skateboard warehouse.
Varda is the first in-space manufacturing
and earth re-entry company.
So what we do is we take
advantage of microgravity to
make unique products since
it's a unique environment
and then we sell those
products back on earth.
People have talked about this for years,
but you're really the first
that are going to try to
do manufacturing in space.
Yeah, exactly. So it's not my idea.
It's been around for decades.
People have just been
waiting for launch costs to
drop low enough to make
this economically feasible.
Varda's first space manufacturing project
will be essentially molecules.
It's been shown that
novel atomic structures
can be formed in microgravity.
The hope is that more
useful things will result,
like new life-saving medicines.
The pharmaceutical industry just thinks
of us as a bioreactor and
then when they walk away,
we just take and we put
it into space real quick
and then we bring it back.
And that's equivalent to
turning the gravity knob
off for that chamber while we
run that automated process.
You guys also have plans for,
possibly, giant factories.
That's more than like the
10 to 20 year timeframe.
The first thing you'll
see is just rapid cadence
of small launch vehicles to
take advantage of microgravity.
The bet that we're making as a company is
that manufacturing comes before tourism,
and as the next step of
commercialization of the cosmos.
For now, Varda's molecular
magic will take place
in this small capsule that
they call the bird bath.
So this one has served its purpose.
It's been on a parachute
drop test quite a few times
and this is kind of the
dilapidated test vehicle.
Inside the capsule is where
the weightless chemistry happens.
I would love to show you
what that looks like, but...
We can't do the payload. Yeah, yeah.
So that's secret.
Which means it's time for
our recurring segment:
A child draws the proprietary technology.
Can you describe it?
Yes.
In as much detail, and we will create
an artist representation.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Hi, my name is Riaan Shah.
I'm going to draw some
pictures for you today.
So we're taking two fluids,
mixing them together,
and then putting them through
a temperature profile.
It is just that interesting.
What's a temperature profile?
Oh, good question. Okay.
So what I mean by that is just
changing the temperature
as a function of time.
So you know, first we put
the crock pot on high to
get everything warm and then you put it
on low and you let it
simmer for eight hours.
I still don't understand
The outer part's aluminium.
And then the inner part is two vessels
with the main sources of liquid:
the solvent and the anti solvent.
They get mixed through a
series of tubes and a series
of gross chambers for the molecules
that we want to formulate,
and then we put them through
a temperature profile
to stimulate that formulation
All done.
And there you have it.
Space drugs are cool, obviously,
but space has more to give. So much more.
And some of those flying rocks
above us are worth a
whole lot of earth money.
Which part of the adventure are we at?
Which part of the adventure.
Jose is the CTO of AstroForge,
which is engaged in the
get rich slow scheme
of asteroid mining.
He too used to work at the bird man's
intergalactic phallus company before
moving into space prospecting
along with CEO, Matt.
Asteroid mining, I mean
it's fairly simple conceptually, I guess.
These asteroids - Well, we know, right?
They contain just huge
quantities of minerals
and elements and the quest
is just to go get 'em.
Yeah. So we're specifically targeting
what are called the
metallic group asteroids
or M type asteroids, right?
We know that they have
a much higher percentage
of platinum group metals on them, right?
These six elements that are
a ton of industrial use cases
that you may have seen or found useful.
I mean, your iPhone itself contains all
of these metals inside it
to make it operate and work.
And we're running out of them on earth.
You can't just go make these, right?
We have to find a new source.
We have to find a new expanse
that we can go grab them from.
AstroForge is not quite ready to send
Bruce Willis and Ben
Affleck to an asteroid,
but they are busy developing
all the tools for the job.
The office is littered with experiments
in vaporizing space rocks and
detecting the valuable minerals inside.
On the day we visited, the team
was preparing for its
first stab into the void.
This will be the first
in space refinery to fly.
So we take an asteroid sample
up. It's already loaded.
We vaporize that sample and we keep
what's valuable to us,
which is the platinum.
So you tested all this
stuff here on earth and then
now this is a chance go into orbit
and see if things work as expected.
Yup.
And then later this afternoon
this goes towards the SpaceX rocket.
That's right. We're going to go
drive this thing up to Vandenberg
and it's going to get
integrated onto the deployer
and then that'll get
integrated onto the Falcon 9.
If all goes well, AstroForge aims
to visit an asteroid for the
first time later this decade
and bring back more than
2,000 pounds of platinum.
It might all sound a bit
fantastical, but for Jose
it's the next logical step
for a space industry he helped build.
I got into asteroid mining
because I love exploration and deep space.
SpaceX was a way for me
to enable that for others.
I just didn't realize that I was
going to enable it for myself.
Right. So it opened up
all these possibilities.
So like in the past, if you wanted to do
an asteroid mining
mission, you would probably
have to buy an entire rocket, which,
you're lucky if it cost 300 million.
Yeah, absolutely.
And you guys are going to pay, say,
less than five, six million somewhere
Yup. For a very high
energy launch to get out,
and so we don't have to
carry as much propellant,
we don't have to build a bigger vehicle.
This is game changing.
People love this car.
From his carefree manner and the fact
that he has time to drive me around LA,
it might be obvious that Tom
no longer works for Elon.
He started a space company of his own.
What stage are you at?
Yeah. We're fully in it. Yeah.
And we're raising our series A right now,
so it's getting pretty intense.
I hear all the founder
story and how hard it
is to get money. It's pretty
easy for us. We've got
It's got to be okay for a Tom Mueller.
Yeah. Can't complain.
We're doing all right.
We'll do fine. Yeah.
Impulse makes space engines, which,
as the name implies, move
things around in space.
Cheap rocket flights have
led to a surge in the number
of satellites and those
satellites often need thrusters to
maneuver into the correct position.
Impulse wants to make
those thrusters powerful
and efficient enough to help
humanity conquer the vacuum.
The future you're laying out is one where
there's lots of stuff up
there, it's moving around,
things are getting refueled,
this thing's going over
there for this job.
If you watch your sci-fi
shows, any of them,
they're moving, right?
They're not just sitting
in one place hanging out.
We're all about movement in space.
We're a space logistics company.
It's an undertaking that naturally
starts in Tom's home workshop.
It's going to be five second delay
and then it's going to
be a five second burn.
Okay.
Everybody ready? On five.
Five, four, three, two, one.
Super cool, man.
That'll light it.
Yes, this is a real prototype space engine
which Tom designed and built
all by himself in his garage.
You don't miss doing the big giant stuff?
20 years at SpaceX. I got my
fill of the booster engines.
And now the next thing is in space.
Yeah.
We want to do it lunar landers
and we got the Mars program.
It's just super cool.
When he is done tinkering
with his designs,
Tom brings them to the Impulse team
so they can be put through their paces
and developed into space worthy products.
How long of a burn?
I have it down to about
80 seconds. We can go longer if you want.
No, that's fine.
This chamber simulates
the vacuum of space,
where the engine will
eventually do its thing.
Elsewhere in the office,
you can find craft
designed to visit other planets.
We got to sack up and land on Mars.
This is a Mars lander development vehicle.
We call it the hopper, that
we're going to take out
to the desert and do hop tests with it.
Yeah, so governments, space
agencies have been to Mars
but no commercial entity
has ever landed anything.
We'll be the first.
You guys are ambitious, right?
It's 2024 for this, is the goal?
26.
Okay.
This is like my early design here.
Tom thinks big and he
has sky-high aspirations
for the new space economy.
I really want to see
manufacturing in space,
like what Varda is doing.
And I think at some point
they're going to start thinking,
why are we lifting all
of our raw materials
from the gravity well of earth up
when it's literally 22 times easier
to bring it from the surface of the moon.
As if moon mining wasn't enough,
how about putting all of
earth's server farms in orbit?
The amount of power to run compute by 2045
will be like the base power
of the planet right now.
The drain on resources
is so high, you need to
put that compute in space and just use
the power of the sun in space,
making the solar cells in space,
and do compute in space and
just beam the results down.
So I think that's a really good use
of space to help save the planet.
Three, two, one, zero. Ignition.
If any of those wild ideas come to pass,
it'll be thanks in no small part to Tom
and his game-changing rocket engines.
At the very least, he's
made a massive contribution
to the weird and wonderful new industries
taking shape in space.
And one day Tom hopes to go there himself.
So you grew up as a kid
being interested in this.
You ended up working on a company that's
sending people to space all the time now.
Is that something you've
ever wanted to do?
Absolutely.
Yeah? I assume you're
not like the six minute,
edge of space kind of guy.
I would imagine you want
a couple laps around the
moon or something like that.
I want to land on the moon.
You want to land on the moon?
My bucket list item would be to ride
an electric dirt bike on the moon.
Jump some graters, you know?
I feel like that is what
should happen for Tom Mueller?
It should. It should absolutely happen.